the European Union is adapting its rules
in the wake of new green energy
subsidies introduced by the United
States speaking in Belgium today the
European commission president said
competition is good when there is a
Level Playing Field first La fonder line
says the generous tax breaks in
America's new inflation reduction act
could lure away EU businesses and
disadvantaged European companies her
announcement comes ahead of an EU U.S
ministerial meeting on trade and
Technology
that you invited me and let's go now to
DW's Terry Schultz who joins us from
Brussels Terry what is the EU most
worried about here
well on the face of it Nick it sounds
great that the U.S would be putting 400
billion euros more than 400 billion
euros in fact into environmentally
friendly processes and products but the
problem for Europe is that a lot of
these measures in the inflation
reduction act are aimed at boosting
domestic production for U.S companies
and that of course could put Europe at a
disadvantage and there's a lot of worry
over this and what Ursula vanderlein is
saying is that the EU needs to rebalance
the playing field she laid out in this
speech in Bruges that the EU needs to
become more assertive in its policies
and and not let the United States take
advantage of it at the same time the
president said that she's very much
urging cooperation over confrontation
but I'm telling you that nerves are so
afraid over this Ira that the head of
the European parliament's trade
committee said today that he believes
the IRA Rises to the level of the U.S
the EU needing to file a complaint at
the World Trade Organization so
certainly uh tensions are very high
right now yeah those are fighting words
listen explain this to me uh Earth the
fonderline was saying that the U.S could
lure investors European investors away
with its green policy so why can't the
EU match these subsidies to you know
move its own goal posts
yeah it's not just luring investors away
it's also shutting out European
companies from benefiting from the
measures under this Ira the tax breaks
and the subsidies that would be
available for North American
companies and and so what what she says
is that the European Union also needs to
look at its state aid policies and make
it easier for companies here to apply
for for federal funding for for funding
from from the European Union and she
said that that's what they're going to
do it hasn't been uh made exactly clear
how those rules might be adjusted but
she said that this is necessary in order
to as she said rebalance the playing
field okay DW's Terry Schultz in
Brussels thanks for that